The joe rogan experience.
There's a paper article I just saw from
somebody posted it I think on twitter
and it was,
it was they ass.
They pulled a guy as an old newspaper
article.
They fold guys,
whether it's okay to spank a woman and
the answers.
They pulled like five or six guys.
There's the old article and they were
all like,
absolutely like she needs it.
If she's out of line and she doesn't
know she's doing just trying to help
her.
I thought that was hilarious.
Yeah.
If a woman needs it,
should she be spanked?
The best part about it was rich read it.
Let's read it
so fucking funny.
Why not?
Jesus Christ.
If they don't know how to behave,
by the time they're adults,
they should be treated like children and
spanked.
That ought to make them grow up in a
hurry.
If it doesn't at first,
they'll soon get the idea.
This is incredible.
I get the idea.
I yes,
when they deserve it.
As a barber,
I've got a lot of faith in the
hairbrush.
Oh my God.
I think there are certain cases when it
is advisable,
when it is.
There's no reason why you shouldn't go
right ahead and do it.
I can't knock the idea.
In my business,
a man sets a lot of the of store sets a
lot of store by the results he can get
with a hairbrush,
properly applied.
Nice little smack.
Now here's the counterpoint though.
Sets a lot of store maybe within the
business term.
Back then,
man sets a lot of store.
Are you ready for the counterpoint?
Yes.
If there is none,
everybody
is.
The best part is everybody takes the
point of view.
This guy parking lot attendant from
Brooklyn,
you Teddy Galella.
You bet it teaches them who's boss.
A lot of women tend to forget.
This is a man's world at a lot of men
who stepped down as boss of a family,
wished they hadn't spanking might help
get back some of the respect they lost.
Look at Teddy.
Look at that as Joey Diaz,
his cousin with a black oxide.
Listen,
cocksucker spank them if they want it.
William Davis,
what does,
William says the toy factory owner.
Yes.
Most of them have it coming to them
anyway.
If they don't,
it will remind them of how well off they
are.
I subscribe to the theory that an ounce
of prevention is worth a pound of cure.
Holy Shit.
Look at him.
Look at evil.
Look and fuck.
It looks like Rutger hauer brother.
Wow.
Does he look like Rutger Hauer and
Robert De Niro fucked.
He looks evil,
man.
Holtzman.
Oh yeah.
It does.
A little like holtzman.
Imagine that guy spanking your wife.
Let's hear what the other people said.
It's not that last one.
That's awful.
I hate your garbage.
There's no radio.
There's no clock.
There's no electric light.
The girls carry water.
They don't wear makeup.
They have their babies by,
they go in shack and squat down and have
their babies.
I live on the ground.
I live on the earth.
I don't live.
I lived in Hollywood and I had all that.
The Rolls Royce and the Ferrari and the
pad and Beverly Hills.
I had the surf board and beach boys and
the beach keeps in the meal.
Diamond in in Roscommon,
the Jimmy Choo and Finn and Elvis
Presley's Mexican bachelor's and all
them guys,
the dean of Martin's.
And then Nancy should not vision a and a
Gasser Shafran will you do it to me?
I hear you did good honey and all that
kind of where you come up to my house
later.
So I went through all that and I seen
that was a bigger prison and the one I
just got out of and I really didn't care
to go back to prison to prison doesn't
begin and end at the gate.
Prisoners in mind,
it's locked in one world that's dead and
dying or it's opening to a world that's
free and alive.
Hold on.
This guy sounds like me
do should have a podcast.
This guy's great.
This one part of the documentary,
they talk about how they delivered
babies at the ranch and they talked
about one part where they got it like a
pair of scissors and just fucking get
it.
Homestyle oh Geez.
Yeah.
How we have babies like that and what a
sick fuck.
But it's a long time ago when I did the
tonight show at one of the,
one of the sets on there,
and I had a joke with a setup,
was kids are like homeless people.
And they go,
could you,
uh,
could you not say homeless people?
I go,
the jokes not about homeless people
listen to the joke.
It's about kids.
And,
and they go,
ah,
maybe just say a Hobo.
I go,
well,
here,
it's a problem.
I'm not a comic from the 1800
[inaudible].
It's a fucking Hobo.
Volvo.
Then they came back home was a great
word.
I love Hobo.
It just didn't fit.
And then they came back with why no,
I go,
so it's okay to make fun alcoholics,
but homeless people,
they are homeless that I'm not judging,
right.
It's what they are.
I just a fine,
what's the context?
How does the rest of the big goal,
uh,
is to,
don't judge.
It was a long,
long time ago.
I don't,
kids are like,
ah,
I don't have kids.
My sister's got kids.
If they're not yours,
you realize what kids really are.
They're tiny homeless people.
There's chase you around the house,
all the land going,
hey,
can I have a dollar?
Hey food,
I'm missing a shoe and I need a ride.
Hey,
I have a ride.
Okay.
It's silly.
It's stupid.
And that's where they,
they just lost their mind over the word
homeless.
Well then,
because I then I said,
uh,
I always give homeless people money and
maybe you shouldn't.
My brother goes,
don't,
he's just gonna go buy more alcohol and
cigarettes.
And I go,
oh,
like I wasn't,
so I'm bringing,
it's still back to me.
I'm so making fun of me.
Right.
I go,
so what am I supposed to say?
Don't give that wine.
Owe money.
Yeah.
A Hobo.
I'm sorry,
I don't have any material about riding
the rails.
Kathleen.
We've done some poles and people are
very uncomfortable with the word
homeless.
Yeah,
I guess so.
Yeah.
It's not funny.
Okay.
They are victims involved here in sound
funny,
but fuck,
why knows societal problem that we're
trying to work through and we don't
know.
It's like,
yes,
it's not two people from off.
This was the guy I was talking about
outreach.
And you'll never hit that.
So all of a sudden.